so I'm Olivia I work at fathom
information design we're over in Boston
and we do a lot of our work is in data
visualization and information design and
we use processing for that which is what
we're going to be using today so
processing is both a community a
development environment and a language
to kind of make it as simple as possible
to get up and running with something
visual on the screen so you can use it
for making 3d you can do what we're
gonna do image processing kind of
looking at the pixel information of
images or kind of pulling in data and
creating things based on that so what do
any of you guys have an idea of what you
think of when you hear image processing
or what that might be yeah yeah yeah so
a lot of it is about kind of
manipulating the information that you
get when you kind of take a picture
usually it's to enhance it so whether
that means you're making it more clear
to be able to kind of analyze
information in there or enhancing it in
an aesthetic way kind of like with
Instagram or snapchat so it's kind of
doing that through code is what we're
going to do today um it uses mix of math
and computer science so a lot of it is
these mathematical functions that
manipulate the different pieces of the
image information and we're going to use
computer science with processing to kind
of mix it all together and create our
filters so there are a lot of different
things you can do it can be as simple as
kind of enhancing the contrast so in
this case this is a photo that's taken
under water on the left and you can't
really see anything so later people have
gone in and just enhance the contrast
which usually means playing with the
values the light and the dark of the
image to start to make out the different
shapes and then they can use it for
analysis or to put in a book sometimes
we take images
you guys were building cameras earlier
using visible light x-rays or another
way of taking images but you're using
x-rays instead of the visible light
wavelengths and then again kind of
enhancing those images so that we can
find different medical anomalies you can
also use x-rays to look at layers behind
paint so a lot of times you might hear a
story about oh they found that like a
person was in this painting and then it
got painted over the way they know that
is through sort of taking these
different images and enhancing the
information in them one that I think is
really cool is so a lot of space images
that you see our mixes of image data
from different telescopes so this is
actually a combination from three
different telescopes I think the blue is
x-ray information the gold is
information from Hubble and then the red
might be a different x-ray telescope so
kind of merging all of those together
and coloring them in a certain way so
that people can start to get scientific
knowledge from the photos and then
there's also this kind of cyclical
process of so now we have cameras that
are really good at recognizing faces so
that our pictures of our family can be
way better but the way we were able to
do that is by looking at pictures of
faces and kind of teaching the camera
what to look for so kind of using images
to enhance later images and what we're
going to focus on today is kind of
manipulating the color information of
our photos for purely aesthetic purposes
so Instagram uses a set of filters which
really is just a set of mathematical
functions that are applied to the image
information and then spit back out your
image with its new colors so in order
for us to be able to do this I'm going
to talk a little bit about the different
ways you might access the color
information of your photo and kind of
how computers see color you might have
talked about this a little bit with the
cameras earlier so it's a good refresher
but let's start with a grayscale image
so on the left is our image of the
baboon and when you have a grayscale
image everything is either is on a range
of black to white that can be stored as
a number usually 0 to 255 and then over
here it's just kind of plotting what
those values are so you start to get a
sense of kind of how image information
can be seen as just sort of a set of
numbers a set of values this is up close
at like one square of your image so
again every pixel in a grayscale image
will have one value and so it can be
from zero for black and 255 for white
and then a color image is usually just
like three layers of that information so
if you're looking at an image in RGB
mode which is pretty standard for sort
of how digital cameras work usually how
computers are thinking about color
information it's three layers of those 0
to 255 values but in this case it's like
from black to pure red or black to pure
green and black tip your blue and then
when we kind of add those all together
with the correct weights you'll get your
full color image so this is one way to
start pulling out the information and
playing with it so in processing you'll
see in the filters that sometimes people
will go through and for every pixel take
out what is the red what is the green
and what is the blue of that pixel and
then you can just say okay add 10 to
read and that will totally change your
image so this is just an example like
what happens when you start playing with
the different RGB values and we'll see
an example of a different kind of color
scheme in a second but when so if this
is my original image over here I've
started like bumping up the blue or like
taking down the red so the whole image
has this color shift but it also starts
to manipulate the lights in the darks
because in RGB mode the lightness and
the darkness of an image
tied to the color of the image so
sometimes you might want to edit those
separately and that's where HSB mode is
really helpful so hue saturation and
brightness so you can also through
processing take the color information of
your image but separate how bright it is
what color it is and how intense that
color is so in this case what we're
looking at across here is where someone
has if this is their original image
they've shifted the hue so Hugh is like
the color you see but they haven't
changed the lightness or the intensity
of the color if we think of an apple as
red and this is also this is chalk which
is also technically read but it looks
more like pink because it has a lower
saturation so this is like when you have
like a pure red versus something that's
lower saturation and then cherries are
also read but they have a darker value
so that's the brightness so again pure
red versus something with a lot more
black in it so you can also think of
this as like if you were mixing colors
with paint if it needs a lot of white to
create that color that it probably has a
lower saturation if you need it a lot of
black to make that color then it
probably has a lower value so here you
can start to play with your image and
say I want everything to be darker but I
want to stay the same color or like with
the butterfly I want to like so like in
this case I the one on the right I
changed just the color but I didn't
change any of the saturation or the
value so you can see how kind of like
these are equally bright and this one in
the middle starts to get more gray
because as I've manipulated the RGB
values I've also manipulated like how
light it is so now we can start to make
filters of our own and the filters that
we have kind of set up for you guys to
play through are these are some of them
so there's this one which is kind of
like posterization so a lot of the time
like if you want to print something as a
poster you kind of have to get it as
close as possible to like black and
white as opposed to like having all the
range of gray values so kind of just
messing around and seeing like what
happens when you start to take out those
middle values of gray and then also
manipulating the colors this one is not
so much playing with the color
information but if you have your image
dimensions and you want to add something
like I've been yet to it being able to
say here's where the center of my images
and then kind of how based on that you
can add a color on top and so adding
this ring on top this one it allows as
you click around the image it'll pick
one color so this is using like hue
saturation and brightness so it'll pick
the hue and then light up all the other
pixels with that Hugh and get rid of the
hue and all the other ones so kind of
seeing how many colors there aren't an
image or being able to highly it like
just the red pieces and then the last
one is so I don't know how many of you
guys have ever played around with like
Photoshop but they have this thing
called blend modes which is like what a
lot of people use to apply different
colors on top and so that just says if
you put a color on top how and what's
the math that it's taking with that
color on top and the image on the bottom
and how it like adds them together so
this is trying to like imitate the
overlay mode which just kind of does
this like taking part of one color and
part of the other and then spitting back
out a new color so those are the
different filters we have today
you
you